this is timor hussein reading for
reviewer richard wakeling
godfall makes a good first impression
from the way sparks fly to the
reflectiveness of its gaudy gold and
marble halls
godfall seems to signal the arrival of
the next generation
beyond the visual spectacle however lies
a game that's immediately familiar and
over reliant on an amalgamation of loot
driven games from the past
8 years or so
godfall's mixture of loot progression
and third-person melee combat has been
described as a new type of genre
the looter slasher the name holds up in
so far as you loot and slash things
but there's nothing about godfall that
feels intrinsically new
diablo monster hunter and warframe make
up a portion of its overt
inspirations but it manages to avoid
feeling completely derivative by pulling
from so many different influences
at once the issues god 4 faces occur
outside of the combat
where its structure and gameplay loop
are decidedly uninspired
the whole game takes place across three
distinct realms earth
water and air upon entering each biome
you're tasked with finding some kind of
door that's locked by a specific number
of mcguffins from here you have to
return to previously visited locations
and defeat a number of mid bosses most
of which are repeats of fights you've
already had
once you've slain each of these enemies
and acquired the requisite amount of
macguffins
you can open the door and fight the
realms boss then you simply ascend
an elevator and repeat the whole process
again in the next realm
this rigid framework quickly devolves
into tedium and wears out its welcome
long before the final credits roll nine
hours in to make matters worse godfall's
end game revolves around yet more fights
against the same bosses you've already
clashed steals with before
there are some new wrinkles including
ways to earn new loot a reward system
that grants temporary buffs
and the prospect of failing and having
to start over but the core conceit of
repeating battles to unlock loot
to repeat more battles is not an
enticing one when that's all there is to
it
part of this tedium is due to routine
level and quest design that does little
more than shuffle you from one battle to
the next
your objective rarely deviates from the
basic task of killing everything in
sight you have no
interaction with the world around you
and there's no nuance to indicate a
sense of history in each locale enemies
simply mill about waiting to die
and the environments end up feeling like
hollow set dressing the threadbare story
provides
little context either offering just
enough of a reason for all the bloodshed
godfall is a game built on monotony that
would fall apart completely if the
combat weren't there to prop it up your
melee repertoire consists of light and
heavy attacks
a snappy dodge and a shield that can
both block and parry incoming attacks
there's the usual assortment of gear
rarities while your weapon arsenal
features everything from giant
greatswords to nimble dual blades
each weapon type is diversified by the
range speed
and cadence of its moveset but they all
share the same four button combo
and an array of abilities that can be
unlocked via a modest skill tree
whichever weapon type you opt for will
come down to personal preference
particularly since godfall's combat is
meaty and satisfying no matter which one
you choose with a palpable sense of
skull crushing weight behind each and
every blow
it can also be surprisingly measured due
to the fact that you can't
interrupt attack animations if you need
to block or dodge
this works well on paper forcing you to
learn enemy patterns and be deliberate
in your actions
but it belies god falls emphasis on
aggression being patient works against
bosses and in one-on-one encounters but
you spend the vast majority of the game
fighting mobs where speed is of the
essence however these mechanics are
undermined by the fact that dying in god
4
is so inconsequential that it's actually
advantageous a lot of the time
falling in battle simply respawns you
back where you died with all of the
enemies right where you left them
whether that means they're dead or
damaged doing so also replenishes all of
your healing items so there's little
reason to avoid letting your health bar
reach zero
unless you want to keep hold of any
energy you've built up this changes
during boss fights
but even these are generously checkpoint
each time you deplete a chunk of the
boss's health
fortunately there is some meaningful
depth beyond the combat's familiar
basics
every weapon type has two unique
variants of special attacks called
southern and northern techniques you can
execute these by spending energy that's
gradually accumulated during the heat of
battle
aside from being a flashy display of
power these techniques are also a vital
part of godfall's soul shatter mechanic
by using light attacks and northern
techniques you can apply soul shatter
build up to an enemy's health bar before
switching to heavy attacks and southern
techniques to bank all of that volatile
energy and dish it out
in the form of destructive soul shatter
damage there are also polarity attacks
that encourage you to swap between both
of your equipped weapons in the midst of
battle by rewarding you with a shock
wave attack and extra damage for a brief
period
it's these physical abilities that
really stand out during the chaos of god
false combat
some loot has a chance to apply
different status effects like bleeding
or add fire and electric damage on top
of your physical attacks
but none of this is particularly
noticeable you know when you've killed
an
enemy using soul shot damage because
they explode in a bright dust cloud
but the effect just kinda gets lost in
the noise
as a result godfall's loot is defined by
basic number crunching
where gear is equipped according to the
highest digits and little else
your preference for a particular weapon
type will factor into this but finding a
legendary warhammer is only exciting
because your damage numbers grow in size
a legendary weapon doesn't function any
different to a common one
they both still have the same combo and
rhythm to their attacks
godfall's meaty combat eventually begins
to wear thin after the umpteenth time of
the same fight
this is a shallow game bolstered by
decent combat that struggles to bear the
weight of an entire game
uninteresting loop mixed with a
monotonous and grindy structure is not a
good combination
and for as satisfying and fun as it can
often be to hack your way through one
battle after another
there's not enough hair to sustain that
enjoyment for more than a few hours
[Music]
you